foreign
I think American middle class cultures
ruining America
middle class culture is ruining middle
America and all Americas yeah it's
ruining everything it's ruining
literally okay yeah I mean we export
ourselves so maybe it's ruining the
whole world let's just extend it let's
get out there on a limb right when I say
that though really what do I mean
I kind of mean American modernism right
the type of America that's existed
post-world War II
where we instill in people a certain set
of values right
we've adjusted our culture you know you
tell your youth that to be a successful
and respected member of society you
leave home at 17 or 18. go somewhere
where you don't know anybody go to
college right and then if you're
successful you can start up a little
nuclear family
out in a nameless suburb or a town that
has the same amenities that every town
has and live a successful kind of
the berry in life right
a little Protestant ethic in the spirit
of capitalism in there right this is a
very particular cultural brand and as
we're no longer in the heady Glory Days
economically of what America was able to
achieve after the world was destroyed
and we were the only people that had
like working machines anymore okay
as some of those
pockets of fat have dissolved in the
United States
we've been left in this situation where
you get extreme social isolation
you get kids that
can't get into the ivy league even
though they feel like they're entitled
to it and then they go spend all their
Time online become in cells buy AR-15
and shoot up a school
right
and I think that it's because we've
really moved away from the idea of
community
in terms of being embedded in a place
you know there are other European
countries with economic issues look at
Italy look at Greece right but they
don't have the same end result because
those people are still embedded in a
community of people who care about them
who interact with them
and you don't have this extreme social
isolation you don't it's just
it's all cultural process in my opinion
you know it's a similar thing with
I think that leads a lot of people to
these extremely Escapist drug addictions
right
and you know to Josh's point I'm not
talking about burning man right I'm
talking about the kind of drug issues I
see in
Worcester Massachusetts right so
yeah I think that this extreme adherence
to the
to that particular brand of the American
dream has ruined our ability to have a
functional I mean things have just
become quite dysfunctional in the
country because of it so I'm I'm trying
to again refine the heresy with the it
is so you said it was American dream
then you said it was maybe more modern
because modernism yeah I'm thinking
about the hundreds of millions of people
in China
who have left their communities and
moved into
the cities and so is this what you're
talking about or is it something
different than this and the same thing
is happening in India right now where
there are
the same kind of migration is happening
of people living leaving these little
Villages that are where they have a
certain identity they know who they are
they're moving into big cities they're
going to college and Beyond they're
mixing up they're they're isolated is
that where we're talking about this as a
general phenomena or you're saying that
there's something else different than
this
yeah I think I do mean it a little bit
more pointed than gradual urbanization
due to like change economically globally
yeah I think there is a particular brand
of the American version of this that
and honestly the people who are most
harmed by it I think are young men
young white men in America right they're
feeling
this sea change under their feet right
we have
there are more women going to college
than men
for a decade now right why
in America
a lot of it is because men are just not
achieving you know dumb metrics that are
kind of meaningless like SAT scores and
gpas at the same rate as women in the
United States I think that it's all
American culture bounded where
if you're failing to meet this High kind
of what's the what's the this Billy
Crystal standard you know from movies in
the 80s and 90s of being able to strike
out on your own with just a baseball bat
and an army duffel bag full of stuff
walking into New York City to like start
your life that you have failed and I
think people are being told that they're
literal failures because they're not
able to achieve this very time
constrained version of American success
and that a lot of the people who are
doing some of the worst things in the
United States right now are people who
have gone through that experience of
failure and it's not necessary
I don't know that there's any analog to
that type of failure in modern China or
India and I'm pretty sure there isn't a
version of that in Italy or Greece you
live with your parents you go to college
and then you move down the street when
you get married right
can I ask Maggie how much of this is the
stuff part like the part that you might
call consumer culture you know that we
measure ourselves by how much stuff we
have and how good that stuff is and the
brands that go with it and then if you
want that you need cash and to get that
cash you move to the city because that's
where the job is that pays more cash and
then you just meet more people who want
the same stuff you know I how much of it
is the stuff part of it and how much of
it is the dream of making it big like
you know the the fantasy of becoming the
next Elon and how much of it is the
leaving where you grew up
to go to a new place because all those
seem to be part of what you're
describing yeah absolutely
absolutely part of it but I would
I would be on consumed
right and keeping up with the Joneses
type stuff to meaningless achievements
right like what's the real difference
from getting a degree from the
University of Georgia versus Emory
in terms of your life trajectory not
that huge but if you don't get into
Emory right and you have to go to
Georgia Southern suddenly that's like
almost like a narcissistic injury right
where you have this
hit to your ego you can never recover
from right and it's just constant
knocking down of ego that injures people
in this way emotionally what I'm arguing
is that those standards are
[__] stupid to begin with like
they're not based in anything other than
the imagination of what we could achieve
on the GI bill in 1950 you know at a
time where we had far fewer people
in the country we had a far different
economic Outlook
and you know I really don't think it's
necessarily about leaving home which I
mean for me it is right personally I'm
coming from this again from an outsider
point of view I didn't grow up in this
type of culture but I'm surrounded by it
all the time now right so
it's all bound up with it but I think
it's more this like absolute like you
said about the Constitution the written
Constitution this fiction we've created
this fantasy of what you need to just
have a basic like respectable life
in upper middle class America
right it doesn't matter how much money
you make even if you're an underwater
welder are you getting the same respect
as someone who went to Cornell
you know in upper middle class Boston
like I don't know that you are even if
you're making double the money
so quick question for you Maggie
yeah and I'll just add a little backdrop
so Johan Hari is an author from getting
his name pronounced correctly he's
written books about addiction and also
depression chasing the scream lost
connections and he returns in a very
compelling way over and over again to
social isolation and I suppose what I'm
wondering is as I look at cultures that
I understand somewhat like Japan for
instance the schooling there and cram
schools and test scores are even more
determinant in a way of your future than
say the SATs are in the US however and
there are social isolation issues in
Japan but you have multi-generational
households and you look at a place like
Costa Rica multi-generational households
and I'm wondering if that is a Crux
component of all of this which it seems
to be is there anything to be done in
the U.S are there changes that you think
we could make culturally that would good
remedy some of the symptoms that you're
describing
celebrate people whose
I mean as that's the form of success
that we should be like
lionizing above meeting what is frankly
like you said right you just said oh
there's multi-generational households in
Japan and there's this really toxic
testing culture right
you know if you think about it in you
know not to get too theoretical here in
an organismic way right where these
different facets of culture work like
different organs and a system as a whole
right like a body that forms a culture
very like Dirk High man way of thinking
about things
you know maybe you can pick pieces in
and out there like you're explaining
these other cultures that you have
experience with
somehow in America we've picked a set of
organs that lead to a particularly toxic
end right toxic individualism
right individualism at all costs really
right we we don't have maternity leave
right like it's just like we don't have
Universal Health Care there's stuff that
just makes economic even neoliberal
sense that we don't do because of like
toxic individualism and I do think that
if we started focusing on again
lionizing people who live happy lives
they'll have fulfilled lives rather than
ones who meet this American archetype
Don Draper
right that that could lead to a lot of
good change you know Josh I think you
had your hand up so I react to a couple
different ways to this Maggie the first
is you know if you live in New York City
you have a lot of politicians who come
here to ask for your advice then they
quickly pivot to asking for money but it
gives you a chance at least to hear from
them and I try to ask them what's
something true about your constituents
that I wouldn't know and one of them
said to me once you think all my
constituents want to move to New York
City they don't the problem is they
don't yes they don't have jobs where
they want to live so the first way I
react to this I totally agree and I
think we are failing to your point Tim
as a society
when we failed to provide employment
opportunities meaningful work a sense of
purpose in the communities where people
actually want to live and we should not
assume that everyone wants to move to
New York City and work for a meta and
live in a loft in SoHo although even if
you work for Meadow you probably
couldn't afford a loft and Soho so that
part I really react to Maggie and I
agree with you I probably disagree with
you slightly on part of it if you look
at places like Italy and China just
picking two examples what you cited
probably their biggest problem going
forward is a demographic one where they
have some of the lowest birth rates in
the world so you pick two societies and
held them up particularly Italy is place
where things are going well I would say
a society where people are sufficiently
pessimistic about the world that they're
unwilling to have children and where
they have repeatedly voted into office
someone like Berlusconi let alone the
person they have now yeah probably
aren't society as I always hold up as
exemplars of what our aspirations should
be so I'm not sure I agree with you on
that point and then the third thing I'd
probably say is the maladies that you're
describing I think are real I think
that's a Confluence of things though I
think one element that absolutely is
consumerism one element certainly is
social media dislocation they're all
combined but if I had to come back to
one I probably would go back to the
point you made and where I started which
is we're failing to provide meaningful
employment a sense of purpose the
capacity to support yourself and you
support your family in a community that
you find meaningful and we've assumed
that's only one type of community and
that's a failing as a society